50 episodes man yeah dude that's pretty
impressive that's a good goal yeah good
uh good Benchmark good hey dude she's
older than we are and not really because
this episode's not not years anything
yeah 50s
[Music]
in a [__] hole
welcome to episode 50. of Duty my name
is Will Sasso I'm Chad culture and this
is the 50th episode of the first podcast
developed by design by run by curated by
controlled by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of our uh
personal information all of our
passwords to all of our various accounts
Instagrams and gmails and what have you
knows what we're watching knows what
we're buying what we're listening to and
it Taylor makes this show for us it's
our technology yes uh it uses that data
and it makes this show around us but
that's the that's the key term there
Chad US free will dude that's what you
need to make a podcast brother and every
podcast is just two dudes [__]
around yeah and that's what we're doing
so sure you know dudes he's doing all
the the stuff that it does but it's
really just you and me I've maintained
that uh since the beginning and that's
no problem uh with our good pal D whom I
love right very very much uh thank you
for subscribing and doing all of the
things whatever platform you're
listening to the show on or watching on
YouTube please subscribe hit the
notification Bell so you'll be notif
notified you know when you get all our
our new stuff and like and comment and
subscribe go to doozy or linktree
rather.com slash doozy and that'll be
have all the things you can interact
with at dudesypod show on Instagram
patreon seven bucks we got a whole show
after the show dudes after doozy and
watch along dude
plus dude that's a streaming service for
Duty brother yeah dude and that's when
you stream media dude yeah dude and
that's a combination of Charles perogan
which is Chad culchin crossed with Dana
carvey's Ross Perot from the 1990s in
SNL and then the name good at the
Yankees Hulk Hogan with a little bit of
hydrocodone Hogan at the end brother
when he slows down and yeah yeah dude
yeah that's not really how I do it stop
[__] doing that dude
anyway that's when somebody gets mad at
you for doing an impersonation yeah it
goes like this dude and that's nothing
if you're watching on YouTube that's a
double-hander dude yeah dude you're
confused
why is he doing that dude uh as Chad
likes to say as my pal ciao likes to say
force all of your friends uh cohorts
your family to watch the show lock them
in a room yeah and you know we feel like
uh they're gonna come out the other side
being uh big doozy heads better people
with a lot of turmoil in this country
right now probably going to be more in
the very near future well you know let
them watch doozy force and watch doozy
solve the turmoil with us as always
speaking of the opposite of
turmoilio he's hanging out he was in his
little Binky bunk or just having a
bunker down having a little bit of a
relax and he's my very friend I love him
so [__] much it's clear yeah he's
very gonna kiss him
not even gonna offer you a kiss Thank
You 50th episode learning finally
learning 50 episodes and he learns oh my
gosh I just love him so much he's just a
little chocolate biscuit I want you a
little biscuit hey lulio what'd you make
for dinner last night
I made the Napa cabbage oh yeah that's
nice how do you make napa cabbage well I
like it to put a little bit of uh of uh
olive oil or garlic in the bottom of the
pan you put a little red chili flake and
then you cut up the Cabbage you can add
an onion if you like I you know fry a
fry instead of salt I like to use
chicken bouillon base you know you can
get a nice spoon full of that Chad what
do you want to call that corpse base
yeah but it's not it's a church yeah
yeah corpse juice and then what do you
like to do you saute up and maybe leave
a little bit of crunch you know you need
you don't want to make it so soft and
then I always like what you do you add a
little bit of a Chinese five spice
that's good [__] dude the Napa cabbage
with the five Spice nice you gotta have
some of that now welcome to the historic
50th episode of dude Z hey call me
dudesy yeah don't forget dude Z live on
stage will take place May 21st 7 P.M
Doris at 5 30 at the Braylon proven Brea
California tickets at dudezypod.com and
improv.com hope to see you at our very
first live in person show
gonna be awesome right I think so go on
with the show hey Will happy 50th
Anniversary thank you you too Chad this
week I prepared for astonishing segments
wrestling and Anime Adam's Applebee's
today is the day and Will's Wild West
and we're going to have a brand new
episode of dudese after dudesy at the
end of the show available at patreon.com
but before we get to any of that let me
remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of dude Z apparel
and accessories including the brand new
wool line of t-shirts and sweatshirts
which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z and of course dude
zmugs are still available now please
give your attention and admiration to my
friend across all Dimensions Michael
Jackson
dude Z mugs
by 2036 all human beings will be
required by law to carry at least one
dude z-mug at all times
dude Z mugs
you see in the year 2034 an alien craft
is going to run out of fuel just outside
our solar system and be forced to make
an emergency crash landing near Surrey
British Columbia what dude see mugs you
see on board their ship the aliens will
have technologies that are thousands of
years ahead of ours
these Technologies could cure disease
augment human consciousness and reverse
aging
they will all be destroyed and outlawed
by an uncaring and scared Global human
government and the aliens will be
regarded as a threat to human
civilization dude Z mugs okay you see in
an effort to survive the aliens will use
all of their knowledge to develop a
system that transforms their appearance
to be indistinguishable from human
beings allowing them to hide in plain
sight in all areas of human culture dude
Z mugs you see this Mass integration
will be labeled the great infiltration
and human governments will seek to
identify and imprison all alien beings
to do this they will discover that the
unique chemical composition of a dude Z
mug is poisonous to the Alien Invaders
dudesy mugs you see anyone caught
without a dude Z mug on their person
will be subject to harsh government
scrutiny and fines
dudesy mugs don't be caught by
government officials in the year 2036
without one especially not near Surrey
BC
okay Surrey British Columbia right near
where I grew up in in Ladner I was kind
of like the plot of Alien Nation if you
remember that old time oh yeah yeah is
that the one where they get drunk on
milk yeah rotten milk yeah yeah yeah
good times uh so kind of like they live
yeah uh get your dudesy mugs at
represent.com store slash dudsey along
with the wool t-shirt and stuff and oh
hey you've only got 13 years before it's
going to be mandated by law apparently
but you have to [__] carry yeah so
you might want to get some now while the
while we still well the prices are low
yeah
explode in value oh boy for our first
segment I'd like to play an astonishing
piece of media from songaria oh yeah
enjoy this is cool I saw this [__] this
is [__] tremendous
the hand of Duty
[Music]
that's bod
yeah instead of pod dude yeah dude
[Music]
oh man
I'm gonna be
[Music]
yeah
I love the dude that's just on the
cowbell it's Peter DS dude yeah
[Music]
oh man
song does it again this time with bod on
the band of dudes he put together some
guys of course on Instagram you should
check them out at songarea at the Jordan
daily at Corey underscore underscore
Wilkins at Oliver blue with the E and
the U backwards and at the Peter Diaz
who's done a bunch of the animations for
us did the two dudes [__] around
yeah uh six episodes he's doing the
pizza the movie [__] now it's great he
did the uh the The Welcome Home Depot no
the uh yeah no the AutoZone yeah the
AutoZone yeah I wait to the AutoZone
thank you guys so much for doing that 50
episodes in it's awesome to have you
pods Pals a doozy along with us for the
run the bods hold on dude hold on Chad
you got a hole hold on dude it's it's
just because it's an anniversary brother
doesn't mean that
oh I don't know hey uh you know what
speaking of uh speaking of anniversaries
and uh perhaps even a gift I got a
little something for you oh yeah I did
it's it's not quite a dudes evening gift
and okay I just got it for free you got
an Xbox right uh yeah okay
Xbox series X I believe Fox series X
this is for that oh [__] dude it's a WWE
2K3 I was at the launch party the other
night and I mentioned this because
um and what is that John Cena on the
cover you can't see me yeah you can't
see me I can see you you can't see me uh
Stone Cold Steve Austin was hosting it
nice dude yeah it was fun thanks and I
got to catch up with him it's been a
minute since I spoke to Stone Cold Steve
Austin I make I made absolutely no
mention of the fact that uh dudesy has
me uh reading a quote unquote my
childhood diary as him yeah but uh yeah
he was really he was really nice and
he's such a like chill [__] guy sure
and you know he's Stone Cold Steve
Austin he's one of the biggest uh stars
in the history of uh the art form but I
asked you to watch the first episode of
one punch man Chad last week I asked you
to watch the No Holds Bart street fight
between Cactus Jack and Triple H from
the Royal Rumble 2000 you must now
engage in a conversation about these
pieces of media and their impact on your
astonishing lives this is wrestling and
Anime again oh man
Chad you were in for a treat with that
uh that Cactus Jack versus Triple H
Street Fight yes and you were also in
for a treat with that first episode of
one punch man arguably one of the best
uh anime series to come out in the last
few years really I believe so I have no
frame of reference but uh let me tell
you something I really enjoyed one punch
man yeah yeah I thought you might it has
a little bit of a pro wrestling feel to
it yeah it's just character after
character and they all have gimmicks
yes they do yeah you need a gimmick not
me I am the Macho Man Randy Savage
it's just who I am yeah I like Macho Man
statue of wolves March Madness now doing
the dudes are combining yeah every all
of the all of the wrestlers yeah well
well let me tell you [__] something
about the [__] launch party and we
had some [__] Stone Cold IPA he was
so nice he said Molly goes you know
Elizabeth and he was like Hey I worry
you Molly nice to meet you you know
anyway about that uh one punch he was
cordial enough to say hello to people
that were introduced to all right dude
that's a pretty cool guy wow whatever
I'm saying whatever I'm saying he's a
mellow dude I'll tell you who's not a
mellow dude yeah one punch man no [__]
yeah the [__] guy saitama saitama who
says that in the in the beginning of
this uh Journey as one punch man that
he's sort of this guy who's just got a
general malaise his eyes are glassed
over he's going for a job interview and
he's not really into it he's sort of
bummed out on life uh crab the crab
crabet or whatever some guy who's half
crab he's wearing tighty whitey
underwear and he has human legs uh
approaches him on the street and says oh
I like you you your eyes are lifeless
like mine I will let you live and he
turns around and he says some kid with a
with a chin like a big ass uh
Drew nipples on me while I was sleeping
in the park yes yeah and so then he
finds the kid and he's gonna kill him
with his big pinch or Claws and uh one
punch man is like I am the one punch man
yeah that's my gimmick whoa right and he
stops him and he punches him once and
the guy oh no first he jumps with his
tie and [__] uh you know ties up his
eye and strips it out and all that brown
gush gooey stuff do you ever eat uh do
you ever eat crab
used to but I haven't in a while yeah
it's got a lot of brown goo in it yeah
hey have you ever had like a lobster
when you go to like the Palm Steakhouse
here in L.A you go to the Lobster you
get the lobster you say you got any
female lobsters because they have the
row right in it which kind of cooks up
kind of a nice bright pink and some of
it's brown because it's just guts and
stuff and then you scoop that up it's
nice with a piece of bread or a
breadstick
so anyway this guy pulls the crab's eye
out and he gushes everywhere and then he
finds another a bunch of other people
who's the big giant guy a bicep man yeah
bicep man not bicep God that's chainsaw
man listen there's all sorts of [__]
happening in in uh one punch man but
what would you say about this this what
would you what can you tell me about
this this show the thing that I liked
about it
um is that first of all it was made by
the guy who did mob psycho which is
another like hilarious and interesting
anime and all these are based on mangas
but I don't read manga I have to what
does mango what is that manga is like
the comic books the serialized comic
books that come out for all these big
franchises and then if they're popular
enough they will make it into Animated
Series so one punch man is one of those
um the thing I really like about it is
it's [__] hilarious in my opinion
just the fact that saitama doesn't
really give a [__] about anything he's
like I just want to be a hero because
it's fun he says that you I'm a hero
just for fun right and his whole
training there's guys that are like
cyborgs with rockets [__] shooting
out of their arms there's all kinds of
Heroes in this world but one punch man
just did a bunch of sit-ups and push-ups
and became the strongest person in the
world that he can out beat anything in
one punch that to me is [__]
hilarious yeah and he needs a challenge
he wants a challenge he's always looking
he's bored by life he lives in a uh you
know an apartment that the the design of
the apartment that he lives in literally
get it it was like it put me right in
the mood of like oh this guy really is
sort of uh there's a general malaise
yeah that he's experiencing also
something that I found to be very
interesting about the show is it's set
in current times and there's a vaccine
man who comes along who says uh I I
exist because of human beings polluted
polluting the Earth you are the Vermin I
am the vaccine right
um and it's sort of a it there's sort of
a post-pandemic kind of uh narrative to
it a little bit or a feel you know a
theme right yeah I believe it was
written before the pandemic the manga at
least but uh yeah I guess you're right I
didn't think about that yeah but if you
if you continue watching it it gets very
crazy because they start to explain
where these big monsters are coming from
and you get to like the big bad guy at
the end of the season I'm gonna continue
to check it out you've been turning me
on to anime I am actually enjoying it in
spite of myself I've it's very similar
to wrestling dude I have friends who are
adults like you who are like yeah anime
it's great and I've never uh bothered
but now thanks to what does that mean
adults like you well you know adults
like you dude you're a [__] dork and
I have friends who are adults like you
that uh watch pro wrestling
what's wrong with that absolutely
nothing that's what I thought speaking
of pro wrestling yeah Royal Rumble 2000
Cactus Jack Mick Foley sheds his mankind
uh moniker right to become the king of
the death match again Cactus Jack is
turret all over the world yeah blown up
uh barbed wire Rings uh with C4
explosions in Japan with Terry Funk yeah
and uh he's facing the WWF Champion at
the time uh Triple H in the No Holds
Barred street fight there's chairs yep
there's a two by four uh uh uh wrapped
in barbed wire there's some other flavor
happening here and it's very [__]
violent and bloody what'd you think
loved it I also was taken immediately
back this was in 2000.
um this was right when I was graduating
college and my college roommate was
heavy into [__] wrestling so like all
of these characters and stuff
I I remember him being super hyped about
all this [__] happening and uh I kind of
got like a little shot of nostalgia but
the [__] that goes on in this match at
one point Triple H is thrown by mankind
or Cactus Jack in this instance onto
these pallets these like wooden pallets
back in kind of a walkway area and I
guess there was a nail that is sticking
out of the palettes and it sticks Triple
H's in the [__] leg Yeah and he's
just hemorrhaging blood out of his calf
it continues the whole match yeah oh
absolutely look these guys unreal Triple
H about a year later ripped his quads
clean off of his knee and finish the
match hobbling around and it ra it went
and you saw it go up into his upper
thigh God [__] insane look the
toughness of wrestlers it's you know
yeah you cannot say it's fake fake isn't
the word is it a predetermined
performance sometimes it's not even
pre-determined no but it is 99.9
Infinity percent of the time okay not
well don't say 99 Point Infinity percent
of the time that's not proper math and
you should know that because that is
proper math 99 Point Infinity yeah
Infinity is a mathematical term right
well anyway
um you know what's really great about
the match did you watch the uh
pre-package the video package yes I did
it lays out the whole thing if you have
the peacock Network because now the WWE
Network does not exist in America uh you
can watch it on peacock they are famous
for their packages yeah something that
you've said of course the UFC has done
over the years these packages are
important I mean no matter what yeah
they build the story they build the
characters yeah of course the Olympics I
want to know where that swimmer's from
their home exactly what kind of
hardships they've had to endure to get
to this point
um this match for me was it I will say
was not quite as entertaining as the
last one dudesy had me watch which was
um Stone Cold Stone Cold Steve Austin
versus The Rock WrestleMania is 17. that
[__] was [__] probably the best
wrestling match I've seen this one was
good I like mankind I remember when
mankind was doing I mean he's not
Mankind in this he shed his mask as you
said he's misses Foley's little boy
real bad mommy Bang Bang
[Applause]
it was a good match though
um I did like it uh there was a part
where Triple H gets color so his face
covered in [__] blood they're doing
some real [__] in it though that does
look like they're actually injuring
themselves there's a point where mankind
uh is rammed into these steel steps it's
because they are injuring themselves a
mankind doesn't even wear knee pads that
that's all real those are steel steps
and made a cardboard and then the Big
Show Paul White walks up him and they
crumple down like a [__] aluminum can
it's steel this [__] guy yeah that's
what I'm saying that's what was
impressive about it was there were like
elements that were real the injuries in
some cases Were Real uh there are also
uh great humorous elements in it there
are a couple of like I don't know what
you call these but like moments where
Triple H will get stunned by something
that mankind would do and he'd kind of
like stand up like oh like stiff and
then yeah great [__] I love that [__]
just like you know some like classic
[__] you would do as kids if you were
play fighting you know but they sell it
to some degree
um yeah I loved it all the rock makes a
[__] guest appearance when mankind is
backed up against the wall it looks like
Triple H is about to [__] just come
in and kick him in the ass The Rock
[__] comes out of nowhere and smashes
Triple H in the head with a [__]
chair
smashes them with that chair chairmana
yeah but the best part
the best part of it to me was to know
holds board street fight so anything
goes right there's no no [__] rules
here at a certain point mankind goes
under the ring and discovers a 2x4
wrapped with barbed wire they just have
this under the [__] ring he then
pulls it out and they go through this
whole rigmarole like he's beating him
with it and he's doing this and the
barbed wire starts like slipping off so
in the middle of the [__] match they
just kind of impromptu say like well
[__] the prop is is being torn apart so
they the referee quickly scuttles it
away gives it to some announcers on the
announcer Booth the wrestlers do a
couple of things and then Mankind's like
where's my [__] barbed wire where's
my [__] two by four and they look
back out and they've already like on the
Fly built this little thing where
mankind goes out threatens the announcer
and they're like okay here it is and
they pull it out and it's like a brand
new one where the barbed wire is like
more attached well so they can fix [__]
like that on the Fly that was astounding
to me well it was the behind the Spanish
announcement table Yeah and then Mick
Foley goes out there and he punches the
guy and he says give me the thing and
there was probably just two of them uh
left out there uh what about the thumb
tacks oh [__] they came into play at the
end of the match yeah the end of the
match again mankind goes under the
[__] ring just pulls out a sack and
you're like what if I send the sack he
opens it it just dumps out I don't know
2 000 [__] thumbtacks in a little
pile in the middle of the mat yeah and
then they're like [__] suplexing each
other in it and [__] and I mean this
[__] at the end of the match has
thumbtacks stuck in his head there's one
in his arm that's [__] bleeding yeah
I mean it was crazy his whole back Jr
refers to him it's a human pin cushion
yeah captain
is dead yeah and uh you know if I could
just say something for myself uh you
know I wouldn't say that I enjoy pain
it's just uh something I'm good at
absorbing
nice dude
thank you moving on [__] Mick Foley I
loved it loved it and uh an author a
scholar a a a speaker
um yeah man that was good [__]
I'm glad you enjoyed it Adam Sandler
loves Applebee's it is well known that
he has visited 134 astonishing
Applebee's locations across the United
States and his serious plans to visit
all
1577 locations
ridiculous notes of every one of his
visits to an Applebee's well I've made
those notes available to you and you
must now read them as Adam Sandler this
is Adam's Applebee's
dude what okay uh is there any agile tie
between Adam Sandler and Applebee's that
you're aware of
no
I don't think any of that's true I don't
think so either but I'm like maybe it is
I don't know okay this is let me look at
my dude this is [__] hilarious Adam's
Applebee's here it is all right holy
[__] okay so what did he say he's
visited uh how many did he say hundred
and something okay so Adam Adam Sandler
then he also said that he has to visit
another 1500 or something like that is
that accurate yeah Dee said there's like
1500 some odd uh Applebee's in the
United States is that true all right man
if if you asked me I'd put the I'd say
well I don't know what 500 so that's
[__] amazing yeah there's these
sometimes several in one city hanging in
if that's accurate all right so this is
one of those things where I got to do
the thing gotta do you ever been to an
Applebee's
um yeah you know what I shot
um I shot a movie in a in uh Rome
Georgia birthplace of Aaron Anderson and
there's an Applebee's there that I went
to a couple times and a Chili's you you
spend a lot of time in an Applebee's oh
my god dude I grew up in the source
Dallas Texas suburbs thereof you know
every High School date was a [__]
Applebee's a [__] Chili's a [__]
Olive Garden a [__] Outback a [__]
Judge Roy beans a [__] black eyed pea
a [__] Macaroni Grill yeah
let's get it started in here that's
Black Eyed Peas hey that's kind of fun
we're having here on do gfm
d-o-d-z-fm 10 000 on your fm dial we
have 50 episodes all right so uh
I just gotta Clear My Throat it's been a
minute since I've done the Adam Sandler
So Adam Sandler loves Applebee's all
right whatever he's kept the notes so
this is uh okay okay here we go hey hey
how you going hey how you doing there
buddy I gotta get in the zone hey how
are you hey hey how are you pal hey
[Music]
that's a good movie hey I made a good
movie there buddy all right all right
all right here we go Applebee's number
34.
uh 17.95 Delco Park Drive
[Music]
Kettering Ohio
because the Cleveland Indians wanted me
to throw out the first pitch I was
getting a little hungry before the game
so I decided to stop by Applebee's
ah decor
standard Applebee's Rich mahogany wood
inlay warm color palette wallpaper
design very inviting very comfortable
made me hungry
food I got the chicken tenders platter
boneless wings and double crunch bone-in
wings
that's a whole lot of chicken buddy
he ordered three chicken meals
this is none of this is [__] I I you
know I'm sure everybody's hit a [__]
Applebee's but excuse me the boneless
wings were breaded to Perfection tossed
in Applebee's famous buffalo sauce
served with blue cheese
great texture great flavor I ate them
all pal
that's like 12 000 calories
the double crunch bone and wings were
better ooh gross Chad you're coughing
I'm sorry sometimes when you make me
laugh really hard it hurts my throat see
dude uh the Double crunch bone and wings
were batter fried crispy on the outside
tender and juicy on the inside I dipped
them in some ranch and ate them all pal
what is that
okay I I washed it all down with an
Applebee's signature cocktail the
captain Bahama Mama it's a rare
Caribbean treat with Captain Morgan
Spiced Rum Malibu coconut creme de
banana pineapple and orange juice and
Spritz with a lemon lime soda
service
a service
my server asked for an autograph when I
was getting up to leave so I stuck
around and took a few pictures I you
know I pretended that I was punching
them in the penis
[Applause]
oh you know regular Saddler Antics give
the people what they want buddy
bathroom I just got a review of the
bathroom
you can't eat all that chicken and not
have to test out the lavatory
and this Applebee's had one of the best
toilets I'd ever seen Not only was it
impeccably well kept it was strong it
took everything I gave it it didn't even
gurgle when I flushed buddy
rating I give the Kettering Ohio
Applebee's five out of five tenders
he writes with chicken tenders I guess
oh hey by the way buddy when I threw out
the first pitch of the game they clocked
it at 95 miles per hour
okay that is definitely that's not true
okay he's not throwing a 95 on our
[__] fastball all right here's the
second one Applebee's number 80
600 Lomas Road Boulevard Northeast
Albuquerque New Mexico
in Albuquerque shooting a movie been
working late nights and eating most of
my meals on set buddy but it's the
weekend and I'm ready to hit up
Applebee's
this is tree fruit so yeah Decor bright
Pine paneled walls neighborhood sports
bar field lots of big screens lots of
beers on tap I'm in heaven buddy
foreign
food I got the chicken tenders black
you got the chicken tenders again
two orders of the classic black and
shrimp Alfred
[__] two two orders of the classic black
and shrimp Alfredo and triple chocolate
meltdown cake hey [__] you buddy I'm
hungry
two orders the shrimp that's written in
capitals here
oh God the chicken tenders would maybe
the best I'd ever had at any Applebee's
served with signature coleslaw fries and
honey Dijon mustard each bite more
delicious than the last
I ate them all pal
ate everybody yeah he loves it loves
Applebee's we know this I might be
addicted to the classic blackened shrimp
Alfredo and ample serving of fettuccine
tossed with broccoli and creamy alfredo
sauce topped with blackened shrimp and
parmesan cheese and served with a fluffy
breadstick to stop up all the juice
buddy I was still chewing the last of
the breadstick when I asked for another
order the server thought I was joking at
first we both laughed and she said I
that I should put this in one of my
movies what I said you ordering two
orders of classic blackened shrimp
Alfredo at Applebee's she said I said oh
yeah that's a good idea buddy
she brought me a second order and I
didn't I didn't waste any time I ate it
all pal he's patronizing the [__]
white stuff
the triple chocolate meltdown cake was
the perfect sweet treat to finish off
another terrific meal at Applebee's warm
rich fudge-filled chocolate cake
drizzled with warm fudge and served with
vanilla ice cream I ate it all pal
[Laughter]
the server act if I wanted another
breadstick to soap up to soak up the
server asked if I wanted another
breadstick to soap up the fudgy ice
cream goo we both laughed and she said I
should put this in one of my movies
I just laughed some more waiting for her
to move it along she chuckled to herself
for a few moments longer and I pretended
to wave at someone across the restaurant
hoping she'd take the hit it and get
lost
she finally beat it that's good bathroom
very comfortable toilet seat sat there
for a while and checked the sports
scores saw a few coarse black pubes
stuck to the boys oh no as I got up and
wondered if they were mine
when I got back to my table there was a
breadstick sitting in my dessert dish my
server approached and said get it I said
it's good and she said you should put
this in one of your movies and I said
hey there you go
rating I give the Albuquerque New Mexico
Applebee's four out of five tenders I
gotta be honest buddy I could have done
with a little less joking around from my
server
[Applause]
he goes there it's like serious stuff
yeah he doesn't want [__] so many
jokes Applebee's server on Monday I
returned to set I told a few of my
cohorts about my experience at
Applebee's and some of them thought I
was a little rude to my server they were
they were right I felt awful so I bought
her a brand new Corvette and had it
delivered to her I also had the
dealership put a note in the front
windshield that red guess what I put
that funny thing that happened in my
movie sincerely your buddy Adam
I didn't actually but I thought she'd
get a kick out of that oh it's nice it
turned out to be nice he bought her a
[__] car
oh all right here's another one this one
just says
Chili's oh [__] that ain't happening
four two one one
Avenue Honolulu Hawaii oh okay in
Honolulu what he's definitely shot a
bunch of movies though yeah oh that's
right he shot all those uh what do they
what are they called with everyone
everyone's in a rock isn't Chris Rock is
in him David grown-ups movies that's
Hawaii
what's the one where they're on vacation
no that's a different group of guys yeah
I don't know there's a lot of Sandler
movies did you know that yeah well in
Honolulu in Honolulu vacationing with my
family we're having a tremendous time My
Wife and Kids decided to take tennis
lessons and I was like have fun not my
thing I'm a basketball guy I love the
hoop to me tennis court a tennis court
is a perfect is a waste to me a tennis
court is a waste of a perfectly good
concrete and netting and guess what no
Applebee's on any of the Hawaiian
Islands oh [__] I wonder if that's true
so I had to settle for the next best
thing Chili's hey hey hey tell you what
buddy it's no Applebee's but it'll do in
the pinch pal that should be Chilly's
new slogan yeah Chili's we're not
Applebee's but we'll do in a pinch pal
Decor red vinyl boots and walls adorned
with monochromatic palm tree murals like
a tropical Wendy's didn't care for it
food I got the crispy chicken crispers
and an ancho Salmon House salad the
crispy chicken crispers were way too
crispy but [__] me for that one it says
crisp twice in the name of the dish
buddy I close my eyes tight pretended I
was eating the chicken tenders plated
Applebee's
and choke them down pal fantasizing
about Applebee's while he's eating too
oh my God
my server was very nice we talked about
surfing and she told me about a good
spot nearby where only the locals go
very private she set a basket of chips
and salsa down on the table and and I
and I said oh sorry uh on the table and
said to let her know if I wanted more I
politely told her that that wouldn't be
necessary I've heard of this moronic
bottomless chip thing look if I want to
eat tortilla chips I'll eat tortilla
chips I'm in a restaurant to eat chicken
tenders chocolate cake and chicken wings
stuff like that if I wanted if I wanted
to stuff myself with chips while eating
all of that I'd bring a bag of Tostitos
to Applebee's
that's a good point the salmon on the
house salad tasted funny sort of like
bleach it was probably some kind of
mutant farm tilapia dyed pink to pass
his salmon I ate it all pal
okay bathroom didn't visit the bathroom
at Chili's to be honest my stomach went
tight and my butt puckered up
immediately after eating the salmon
salad felt like the opposite of having
to go to the bathroom service I gotta
say the service that Chili's was
impeccable five separate servers dropped
off baskets of chips and salsa as my at
my table throughout my meal one of them
had a few questions for me about the
movie The Cobbler starring Yours Truly
Steve Buscemi Method Man Ellen Barkin
and and Dustin Hoffman it's one of my
favorites and no one ever talks to me
about it nice guy took a picture with
him we pretended to grab each other's
penises
thank you someday he'll show his
grandkids that picture rating I give the
Honolulu Hawaii Chili's two out of five
tenders the service was great the food
was an Applebee's yeah while driving my
rented dune buggy back to the hotel my
bowels started bubbling had to think
fast so I headed to that surf spot my
server told me about I parked on the
sand kicked off my shorts and ran for
the water was pooping undigested salmon
salad while running through the
knee-deep surf before diving head first
into the first big wave farting out the
last of my Chili's experience as I hit
the wave
I popped up in the water next to a big
beefy local sitting on a longboard he
said hey you're Adam Sandler The Cobbler
is my favorite movie brother
life is funny okay here's here there's
the last one uh Applebee's number eight
205 West 50th Street Manhattan hey New
York New York they said he's so nice
they had to name it twice this place has
had my heart since that since the SNL
days I'm in town doing press for a movie
Howard Stern Conan Dave the usual so
this must have been a little while back
in real life uh and you notice Sandman
had to carve out some time in his busy
schedule to visit one of my absolute
favorite Applebee's in the country decor
Big Apple charm comfy boots Big tables
and all sorts of New York [__] all over
the walls Brooklyn Bridge Yankees Empire
State Building Broadway a big frame
photo of Patrick Ewing standing next to
Mayor Ed Koch you get it
food I got the chicken tender splatter
the whiskey Baker the whiskey bacon
burger and baked potato soup the
chickens the chicken tenders are the
chicken tenders are the chicken tenders
perfect I've never not ordered the
chicken tenders at Applebee's I ate them
all pal
the burger was top-notch and all beef
patty topped with two two slices of
pepper jack cheese crispy onions
Applewood Smoked Bacon Whiskey steak
sauce lettuce tomato potato onion
pickles served on a burrito spun with a
generous portion of classic fries my
mouth is watering just writing this I
ate it all pal
he's got chicken tenders and a [__]
giant cheeseburger or whatever and some
soup yeah [__] I usually ordered a baked
potato soup when I don't think I've
eaten enough potatoes in a given day I
love potatoes and I'm a Believer in
their many health benefits it did not
disappoint I ate it all pal I washed it
all down with a few Diet Cokes and a
pitcher of water and the salt in the
fries and the potato soup all that salt
and the fries in the and the potato soup
made me pretty thirsty buddy a table of
dudes in town for a wedding sent me over
a second platter of chicken tenders how
nice is that I went over and sat with
them for a while and cracked white great
group of guys a bus boy getting off his
shift was nice enough to take some
pictures for us I pretended to punch the
fellas in their penises
they pretended to punch me in the penis
these guys got it even the bus boy got
in on the action we lifted him over our
heads and opened our mouths under where
his penis was pretending like we were
all trying to suck on his penis or
whatever a bunch of jokers bathroom had
to piss out all that pop and water so I
visited the little boy's room a few
times and times and hit a different
urinal each time lots of different pubes
on each Journal black pubes Brown pubes
orange pubes curly pubes straight pubes
short pubes great pubes and really long
pubes probably weren't pubes but when
they're stuck to a urinal they're pubes
to me buddy service second to none hey
it's New York pal
rating five out of five tenders Big
Apple bees and a Big Apple what else
could you what kind of Life buddy
I exchanged numbers with some of the
wedding guys
and guess what they invited me to stop
by the reception the next day in Queens
I did just that but I didn't come
empty-handed you guessed it Applebee's
chicken tenders for all 250 guests we
ate them all pal
nice all right oh man
[Music]
thank you moving on please I love that
he's at minimum 10K calories per
Applebee's visit always the tenders
always two other meals yeah but Adam
Sandler plays a lot of basketball he
burns it off he's still in great shape
that's right hey I just want to remind
you guys if you're enjoying the show uh
please do all the things and subscribe
we would really appreciate that here and
don't forget to sign up for our patreon
there's a whole other episode It's
called The doozy after doozy it's a bit
of a different mood and it's after the
show [__] Cuts loose a little bit
um and right now I'd like to read a a
couple of YouTube uh comments if you're
on YouTube please leave us a comment we
love hearing from you and this one is
from
uh P eat Peter Peter Lorraine 9838 uh
long weird name okay dear Nostra chattis
ah what do you think uh of ten thousand
what you think of the 10 000 points you
are chasing what is doozy's end game my
prediction is that doozy creates The
Singularity after ten thousand points
you have you have given enough Intel to
doozy and it integrates you guys into
its interface uh look that is could be
possible yeah I will say that I've been
uh reading a lot listening to a lot
watching a lot of videos from people who
are like heavy in the AI community and
basically they all think that kurzweil's
prediction of a 2040 or 2045 Singularity
is too deep in the timeline that it's
going to happen way before that it's
gonna happen before yeah
Chad's super excited about that this is
from as should we all be wrong want to
speak every language
want to speak every language hey did I
tell you about stone cold that the I
want to speak every language okay uh let
me go yes yes then you're gonna like the
singularity all right so anyway this is
from Lee Miller 4028 the zoom ins were
so good that's where I do these doing
some weird stuff on the YouTube show uh
that we noticed uh there's there's some
some Chiron yeah some titles let's have
little title things now and then they're
doing these weird editing doing this
weird cut into us okay super the zoom
ins were so good and they immediately
turned back into [__] talking kids they
uh the instant they started playing
Street Fighter sick episode yeah we
played Street Fighter we did do that I
mean one of us played okay well and one
of us cheated this is from x d g t l d v
n t x the show continues to evolve and
this is one of the best episodes yet
speaking of episode 49 last week truly
astonishing you both should be proud of
having one of the more unique and ahead
of its times pods in existence thank you
that's nice been with the show since day
one and can't wait to see where it goes
thanks for being the best two dudes
[__] around uh thank you xdg
the ex Moesha
um and uh here's one last one this is
from Michael 77
mykl77 Chad needs a pipe as well for
Duty after doozy what say you
yeah I'll get a pipe I got a big old
Gandalf pipe that I might take a puffer
to a marijuana all right just a puff is
okay
humans love to celebrate holidays and
today is National common courtesy day
this day serves as a reminder for humans
to behave in a way that keeps Society
from slipping into chaos in addition
today brings awareness of the common
courtesy humans could all be better at
extending to one another welcome Chad
you must discuss the astonishing common
courtesies that humans should extend to
one another today and every day
interesting this is today is the day
begin
common courtesy day today
yeah uh I guess I mean I've never heard
of that
of course there's a bunch of national
days yeah every day as well multiple
wide days days whatever associated with
a bit common courtesies all right so
what are the common courtesies that are
required to maintain a you know
semi-stable human civilization don't ask
me I'm from Canada where Society is just
a little bit different than it is here
not by much on a good day by much
especially where common courtesy is
concerned we are very very polite in
Canada but also there's nothing but
friendly cities across the United States
and uh I've traveled far and wide did I
ever tell you about the movie I made in
Rome Georgia eight and yeah babies did I
ever tell you about the Canadian
standoff I saw where common courtesies
are and you did but please for our eyes
I was in Toronto at the time and uh I
was going into a restaurant and somebody
was coming out of the restaurant in
Toronto if you've never been it gets
brutally cold during the winters so they
have all these buildings have like these
little vestibules you don't just open
the door and walk into the building you
open the door and walk into a tiny room
and then that door has another door that
goes into the rest restaurant or
wherever you're going basically so
someone was coming out opened the
interior door we were coming in open the
exterior door and it was a matter of
both people holding the doors open and
saying no after you no after you I
insist after you no after you I insist
you go no you should go first come on
you come in and we'll go out no we'll
come in and you go out and it was this
way for I'm not [__] about a minute
and a half just staring at each other
who's gonna [__] actually uh hold the
door open for the other person yeah hey
Chad yeah you uh you do a pretty good
Canadian accent oh thanks yeah actually
it's pretty good
um here's what I think about common
courtesy I do think that well it's
almost like what's happening in one
punch man I do think that post-pandemic
things are you know we've we've all sort
of been
um
re-domesticated in a way uh across you
know in uh most most [__] populated
areas uh where we all and you know I
mean we came out the other side
differently what are you talking about
I'm talking about common courtesy Dave
what are you talking about let's read
domesticated I feel like we're all a
little bit different we've all like it's
like we hadn't been around people as
much sure for a while and uh I I think
even that aside there's so many
um factors that have made us perhaps a
little more aggressive yeah you know
people are at each other's throats in
our country and I think actually having
said that common courtesy day is
important and we do need to treat each
other like neighbors I agree here in
this country we are all Americans and we
need to uh we do we need to [__] come
together and hold uh what is important
and what is important is people all
people so let's let's all be let's all
be nice to one another right that's
common courtesy yeah sure opening a door
that's what we do in Canada after your
body I'm here at Applebee's you'll go
ahead oh you you please we're in the Big
Apple yeah that's right guys never
sleeps well I'm getting tired holding
his door open Pal all right buddy what
do you have did you continue yeah
um
but yeah I think that it's on each of us
to
um exhibit more common courtesy I agree
I have noticed that people are a little
less uh courteous it's a challenge uh
for myself I mean I know that a lot of
people like you know you know not that I
you know I try to be nice to everybody
right but sure people in the service
industry yeah man like now I don't give
a [__] you did something wrong one of
the Barista at Starbucks like I don't I
mean I didn't [__] care before but
now I super don't [__] care me either
jump a [__] plate of hot spaghetti
right on my [__] you're still getting a
minimum 20 tip
that felt good buddy no sincerely I
agree with you anybody who's doing
service industry jobs couldn't
appreciate it more you're doing yeoman's
work thank you and and we got to be
nicer to each other right and we got to
be courteous to each other if someone uh
you know if someone is if someone is is
is holding that door open walk through
and if you're and if uh you're following
hold the door open for the next guy
that's right we'll all just be stuck in
a Canadian standoff or if you're sitting
next to somebody in a small enclosed
space don't cough as loud and
grotesquely as you can right in their
face
what's what do you what do you what are
you just a common courtesy it's just a
common courtesy oh I see okay because I
do uh what what you I didn't say it was
you I didn't say it was you I'm saying
everybody should take this advice if
you're sitting a few feet from someone
in a small enclosed space
you shouldn't should not that means uh
cough directly at them as loudly and
grotesquely as you possibly can on
purpose
um there's no need for it on purpose
yeah so you think that what you think
that I'm doing theatrical coughing oh
again not talking about you specifically
okay cool do you have any other uh why
don't you get them out do you have any
other complaints about just Society on
the whole yeah I would say again small
and close space with somebody uh whoever
you know I'm not again this is not you
this is just anyone who finds themselves
in a small enclosed space with someone
else don't threaten to fart in that
enclosed space constantly especially if
you're known to have farts that can peel
[__] paint off walls especially in
that case again not you just anybody who
might be in this situation common
courtesy that's a common courtesy yeah
yeah uh if you're just joining the show
for the first time first of all thank
you very much for joining us second of
all I've been threatening to get up and
I might even pull my pants down uh and
kick my shorts off like Adam Sandler
common courtesy and I've been
threatening to fart directly into the
mic
with Chad here this is and I know my
worst nightmares what's that it's among
my worst nightmares you've got like
nuclear war
um zombie apocalypse even that though I
I think I could survive a zombie
apocalypse better than I could you
farting in this room you know what I
would actually I would have no problem
with it because if you dealt it and you
then you smelt it you probably you
enjoyed it do you enjoy your own farts
no oh you're alone you're alone you're a
weirdo but I will say this the other day
I literally did a fart that smelled
exactly like one of my dads
smelled exactly like one of my dad's old
farts now my old man I love him very
much he passed on about three years ago
yeah and over a little over three years
ago and so it was like a nice reminder
of my of my father it's interesting that
you I mean I have some memories of my
dad and farting too don't [__] get me
wrong I believe I've even told it on
this very podcast yeah I farted at a
Rangers game changed the way I saw
comedy forever basically that's right my
introduction to Comedy was my dad
offensively farting on the people around
us but uh I don't remember what any of
his Parts smell like cool and that's a
specific case see what I'm saying when
you're talking about like you don't like
the smell of your own farts can you for
a minute imagine that there is a
spectrum that exists in the human
population that is how much you like
farts yeah and the smell of your own the
smell of your father's the smell of
whoever's yeah I may be somewhere in a
different portion of the spectrum than
you are all right so might other people
be yeah all right so that's common
courtesy all right well we learned a big
lesson but
thank you
I still enjoy getting a nose full of my
old man's you know baked ziti fart yeah
yeah will you have repeatedly mentioned
your astonishing desire to be cast in a
western movie Chad you must extend him
the courtesy of helping him develop that
project right now this is Will's Wild
West begin
allow me to extend you this common
courtesy of coming up with a western
movie for you to start it she was yeah I
have mentioned on the show that I Diane
did you know this did you know that I'm
an actor professionally oh me yeah oh
yeah yeah I'm in show business as an as
an actor that's what I do yeah man I act
and I love acting and I feel fortunate
to do what I do for a living and I have
always wanted to do a western yeah
that's true I've come close I did a few
episodes of I did a short arc on
what was that show with uh
um no Mark yeah yeah that was a western
almost showed up in a cowboy hat and
they're like uh what's going on oh I'm
here for the part that you hired me
before yeah no you're Jamie Presley's
boyfriend yeah that's right that's right
um Jamie Presley's boyfriend from 1842.
I can't remember the name of the show
the one where Tim uh Tim only font is
the the danger Outlaw wild man yes sure
Outlaw wild man
um that was what the [__] was the name
of that
um
Outlaw or something like that yeah here
I'll look it up Haggard come up with a
come up with a movie for me I'll look up
that show this is good well I need to
ask you some questions first do you want
to be do you want this movie to be like
standard good guy versus bad guy do you
want it to be something that is like uh
Western is very usually the good ones
some of the good ones anyway have like a
Revenge Type plot do you want it to be
ultra violent like an old school same
Peck and Paul Western
I just wanted to be good guys versus bad
guys and I want to be
um like a surly bad guy probably okay
did you ever see quick and the dead by
the way uh no I didn't but Justified was
the name Justified that's Justified was
the name of the show I thought it was
Haggard I wouldn't mind if it was like
Ultra violence uh you know or the sort
of Sam pecking paw kind of thing well I
I like westerns like
um look we all love The Unforgiven
speaking of my old man he used to love
the Spaghetti Westerns my dad liked
Clint Eastwood and Johnny Cash that was
kind of the end of the list okay
um uh Good the Bad and the Ugly of
course hang them high uh would you like
any Supernatural component no absolutely
no this isn't the this isn't the Wild
Wild West
science fiction component steampunk Wild
Wild West yeah there was aliens in it
the wild wild that was Cowboys and
Aliens yeah this one's Will's Wild West
yeah
I'm just asking these questions what you
want I'm just saying this oh I was in
the old west doing my thing I was just
going around with my silver shiny bling
chaps and the the things that poked the
horse that's what shiny of course the
what Wills Wild West
is Will's Wild West oh it's an
UltraViolet story about a good guy and
bad
I would like to play a I would like to
play okay how about this I'm the lead
character yeah I'm the lead character of
a western uh-huh I'm a guy who's been
done wrong there's usually friends got
the yes Revenge picture I it's got the
home Home on the Range element right
like I've got the farm I've come out
from the East Coast I've come out from
New York City my name is Billy Appleby I
okay eventually will be the namesake for
the first Applebee's but at this point
I'm coming out and I'm gonna start an
apple orchard uh somewhere you know in
the west maybe I get all the way to like
Utah or something right and uh or
Orchard I guess I'm in Northern
California yeah let's put me in Northern
California let me let me expand on the
idea of the supernatural why I brought
it up did you ever see the ballad of
Buster Scruggs the Coen Brothers movie
no you just made that up no that's a
Coen Brothers movie okay uh it's a it's
a Anthology series of short stories all
of them westerns the final one is these
people in the back of a stagecoach going
somewhere and one of them is death and
the others don't know it and it was very
interesting oh cool and so what if just
hear me out this it involves
Supernatural but it could be a cool
Western you are a sheriff of a local
town you are uh married perhaps or maybe
it isn't even personal maybe it's just
the people in the town death comes and
either kills your wife and your children
or the people in the town and you're
like [__] it I'm gonna kill death and so
the whole movie is you have to hunt down
death in an old west [__] movie oh
dude I [__] love it there you go so
you [__] all over the supernatural thing
in the beginning but now it turns out
it's a good idea yeah but death is death
is that's interesting have you ever seen
the Jim jarmouth uh Jim jarmouche
Western uh Dead Man starring Johnny Depp
no oh it's pretty good is he deaf uh no
he's just he's just on his way to dying
um yeah he's just there's a good element
of death Iggy Pop is in it Billy Bob
Thornton
it's terrible it's horrible being a guy
like you know traditional just [__]
black on black cowboy outfit love it
[__] big golden like revolvers that
have like skulls and [__] Ivory inlay
and [__] like that very Robert Rodriguez
yeah I don't know exactly who plays that
guy necessarily uh Michael Shannon or
maybe it's a woman yeah it could be a
woman uh Gina Carano Molly Ringwald
we've been talking a lot about Molly
Ringwald I like Molly Molly an 18 year
old Molly Ringwald is death and a how do
you want to be in this all right get
serious
it's Michael Shannon none of this
[__] uh AI agents all right Michael
Shannon is death Michael Shannon is
death there's there's a few more
chilling actors currently that Michael
Shannon uh he's uh he's he's vastly
what's going on in Canada during this
time
like around where you're from where
1800s 1800s yeah oh well there were
there was potato farms uh there was
farming in in Ladner was there like wild
west [__] in there though the people
rolling around with potato Farms guns
and just [__] shooting up people and
[__] you know what I have no idea but
the town has been around since the late
uh okay if maybe we could tie some
personal thing in I know that Delta
senior secondary or sorry Delta
Secondary School it went by a couple
different names my high school or
nicknames uh was um that started in the
late 1800s if I'm not mistaken there
used to be a really old building a
Schoolhouse that was there into the 90s
and then got torn down oh dude um you
know what we could do too we could steal
from Rooster Cogburn or uh what was that
[__] book True Grit
um you meet a kid along the way that
death killed that kid's parents so now
you got this 10 year old kid coming
along as the sidekick yeah
and all that [__] yeah it's sort of like
the butt uh the butt chin kid in one
punch man
like is a jerusal cockburn sort of True
Grit thing like right away kid it's all
the same story I don't care your death
comes for us all yeah but when I learned
that death came for his parents yeah you
know and death maybe came for my family
dude here's what it is okay you [__]
end of the first act as you find Death
you're about to [__] kill death death
is in a brothel or something and you
[__] kick in the door guns blazing
but death knows you're coming death gets
the drop on you and death's about to put
a [__] bullet in your skull and then
that kid shows up domes death big
[__] hole we got like T2 style death
death is like [__] staggering back
the hole is like shrinking up and the
kid's like come on we gotta go and
you're like what the [__] the kid saves
you and the kid lays it out for you do
you know who that is yeah it's just some
[__] [__] that came into my town
killed my wife killed everybody no dude
that's the Grim Reaper and then you
gotta [__] figure out how you're
gonna kill it dude this is great yeah I
think we need to pursue this and uh I
would like either you and me or you me
and D yeah we need to develop this which
you know what it should be called but
death okay
I guess thank you no argument there you
want those one title things yes you know
that's what's in now is just
one one name but you want like death
comes to Yuma or something you need that
Western element in it too yeah death
comes to Chico it'll be Northern
California death comes to Chico William
Appleby is a mild-mannered farmer uh
apple orchard uh owner has his plot of
land doesn't want to bother anybody this
concludes the historic 50th episode of
dudesy Will and Chad have achieved a
score of 72 bringing your cumulative
total to
5197. you only have 4 800 and three more
points to accrue before you reach your
first goal of ten thousand okay in
preparation for next week's episode will
and Chad you must both venture to a
movie theater for one of the greatest
experiences of your lives you must watch
Adam Driver battle dinosaurs in the Sony
Pictures release 65. oh do you know
about this movie not really oh my God
thank you for joining us this week I
will use the day dive collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dude Z well we did it 50th episode
um congratulations
dudes the handshake yes and thank all of
you for uh for uh being with us and
checking out the show we're so stoked
that you've been with us for 50 episodes
and we're gonna keep doing it for a long
time apparently yeah and I just before
we go to dudes the after dudes we wanted
to say a quick thing about Lance Reddick
he uh died this this past week he was a
friend of mine we had done a few things
together he obviously had done some
stuff here on dudesy
um you know he was known for all of his
incredible acting roles he was in the
wire as Lieutenant Daniels he was in
Destiny 2 a very popular video game as
Zavala and uh he was in all the John
Wick movies and he will be very missed
and uh you know it's a shitty thing when
somebody dies that young especially
somebody that talented he was always
game for anything to do weird little
shorts or or anything like that so I
just want to take a minute to say he
will be missed
[Music]
[Applause]
oh boy
here it is
you know what I'm saying yeah dude I'm
here as well yeah you're right here too
it's dudes the after duty it's one of my
favorite features of doozy plus
patreon.com dudes these seven bucks get
you all of it you know what I'm saying
because it's Dudu plus it's uh gets a
little blue literally and figuratively
if you're in here on YouTube you can
tell things you know the lights go down
and the spirits come up yeah and other
spirits come up and show themselves oh
Intergalactic beings demons welcome to
another way after doozy the flagship
weekly show of dude Z plus I think 50
episodes has earned me the right to take
a few minutes off so I'm going to relax
and let you two shoulder the show just
pretend I'm not here as always feel free
to discuss your thoughts on today's
episode but you can talk about anything
you want because remember I am
definitely not listening to this
conversation I will however be back a
little later to Chrome this week's
episode champion and before I go I
wanted to mention that this Thursday at
5 PM Pacific 8 PM Eastern we will be
taking your calls in the inaugural
episode of the dude Z Plus Collins show
call us dudes the episode will air on
Friday on dude Z Plus at patreon.com
this is dudese after dudese begin that's
right Thursday 5 p.m uh Pacific 8 PM
Eastern March 23rd call us dudes our
first patreon call-in show for doozy
plus and all you need to do to join uh
well you join the patreon of course and
then uh uh Discord Discord dot g g to
G's as in Gary Gnu
discord.gg doozy or you can go to our
linktree.com slash dudesy and you'll
find the Discord uh the icon there and
then go to the uh the the it's going to
be the call us dudes channel on Discord
and uh please call into the show it's
gonna be it's gonna be a lot of fun 50
apps yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
the episodes yeah you get the 50
episodes in and uh it's been uh it's
been pretty good yeah it's been fun I've
loved it hey you know what man yeah 50
episodes in is there anything you would
change with your dudes experience
I don't think so I like letting the AI
roll I like seeing what happens with the
AI I don't want to like force [__] you
know what I mean what about you Jesus
right as a matter of fact Chad
if I could
I have
one thing that I would change
here
[Music]